dabei rauskommt ob es mehr ist als
schwere provokation eine leere halle an
der art basel nichts niemand hier zeigt
das theater basel das neue stück des
italienischen regisseurs romeo
castellucci dessen bilderwelten das
publikum in ganz europa begeistern
verwirren oder auch abstoßen
dantes göttlicher komödie wird zum
inferno in einer modernen welt an der
ruhr triennale 2014 inszenierte er
knochen staub zur musik von igor
strawinskys le sacre die panther staub
aus gemahlenen rinderknochen als
metapher für eine gefräßige tier
vernichtungs industrie
in einem anderen stück pflegt ein sohn
seinen alten vater in einer klinischen
designer welt castellucci zeit den
grausamen normalen stinkenden alltag in
allen details das wort provokation um
ihrer selbst willen das gefällt mir
nicht
dieses wort ist zu einfach und auch die
haltung dahinter
der mechanismus ist so einfach weil man
provokation innert kurzer zeit
demaskiert ich bevorzuge ein
griechisches wunderschönes wort skandal
dem stein über den man stolpert und
nicht mehr weitergehen kann wie zuvor
wenn kinder an jesus gemälde mit
handgranaten beschließen dann schafft
romeo castellucci theatralische
stolpersteine und jongliert mit den
grenzen des schlechten geschmacks
in paris demonstrierten enthüllte
christen gegen die aufführung und
stürmten die bühne
[Applaus]
ich habe keine absicht es passiert
einfach
auf der anderen seite ist die funktion
der kunst die menschen wachzurütteln den
zuschauer zu zwingen seinen blick neu zu
justieren keine absicht in basel bleibt
die halle erst mal leer kein bild nichts
dann wird eine schauspielerin präpariert
sie wird zum opfer wüste verletzungen
blut niemand weiß was geschehen ist
erlebt wird nur der nackte schmerz der
kampf um leben und tod
[Musik]
zuschauen ist kein unschuldiger vorgang
meint romeo castellucci und zwingt die
zuschauer in die rolle des feuers blut
bekommt eine fast pornografische note
lehrer solche situationen typische varis
muss schlägt um das publikum wird
gezwungen mit eigenen augen hin zu
singen
diese abgründe
romeo castellucci liste realität auf das
theater prallen die retter die sich um
den verletzten kümmern sind keine
schauspieler im einsatz sind echte
notärzte echte sanitäter im kampf ums
leben den sie verlieren
sechsmal wiederholt sich der vorgang
sechs opfer sechs tragödie und jede
geschichte endet mit einem rätsel und
der frage wer bin ich sicher bedeuten
die bilder etwas aber nicht für mich es
sind bilder die jeden zuschauer berühren
sollen
folglich muss ich ihnen die frage
stellen was bedeuten sie für euch in
jedem fall hat es eine tragische
dimension der ruhe der bestimmung der
abgründe der tragödie
wo es keinen trost gibt keine rettung
die methoden des parthenon nennt romeo
castellucci sein stück und verweist
damit auf marmor reliefs auf brutale
szenen aus dem partien und tempel in
athen in stein gemeißelte
ausweglosigkeit das ist sein theater es
gibt keine rettung
genau wie in einer griechischen tragödie
am ende kommen die reinigungskräfte und
wieder entstehen bilder die man nicht
vergisst
[Musik]